there is an important and official
announcement today on Michael Knowles
show policy we have always had a zero
tolerance policy on this show for fake
Republicans and totally contrived to not
reverse YZ but I haven't always enforced
the law and that this has created a
perverse incentive for the squishes of
our party to gin up fake news so today
to show our seriousness about tackling
this problem we will separate fake
Republicans from their party as well as
fake news from reality then theologian
George
Weigel joins the show to discuss chaos
order in our turbulent times
speaking of turbulence soccer fans in
Mexico caused an earthquake during the
World Cup daily wire to sports analyst
Jeremy the god-king boring will join the
show to discuss the suburban fallout
finally its Juneteenth on this day in
history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
do you know what other time it is
there's so much is so much going on that
we have to talk about it's also time to
join the conversation on Tuesday June
19th by my calculations that is tomorrow
at 5:30 Eastern 2:30 Pacific Ben Shapiro
the big boss himself will answer your
questions moderated by the beautiful and
dauntless Alicia Kraus the QA will
stream live on YouTube and Facebook for
everyone to watch but only daily wire
subscribers can ask Ben questions many
are called but few are chosen to submit
your questions log into daily wire comm
and head over to the conversation page
to watch the live stream type your
question into the daily wired chat box
and have it read and answered live on
the air once again subscribe to get your
questions answered by the big boss
himself Ben Shapiro Tuesday June 19th
tomorrow 5:30 Eastern 2:30 Pacific and
join the conversation
can we look we got there is so much fake
news and so many fake Republicans
stabbing their fellow partisans in the
back today before we get to that let's
talk about something nice because you
know it's really frustrating when this
happens I want to talk about something
nice I love these guys you can probably
see them wearing it
Peter Millar Peter Millar is my favorite
clothing that's it I know some of you
saw me without any clothing in that ad
for the conversation a little while ago
you can thank Peter Miller that I'm now
wearing clothing and saving all of your
eyes I love it it is my favorite
clothing Bar None period Peter Millar
was founded in 2001 with a single
cashmere sweater it's grown into a
premium American lifestyle brand
featuring a wide range of casual
sportswear tailored menswear and luxury
performance golf apparel the Peter
melora's comfort fit quality and style
are all setting the standard in menswear
so you see what I'm wearing here it's a
nice white with navy checked sports
shirt you know button-down oxford
button-down it is the best and one of
the reasons is if you're like me you
might perspire a little bit for a lot of
people it's because they're playing golf
or they're out there working out or
they're exercising or it's a hot day
whatever me I'm of Sicilian heritage so
I sweat in it freezers you know I could
go into an industrial freezer I'd still
be sweating with a Peter Millar you
don't really see that you don't sweat
through the clothing it's so nice so
comfortable and you won't look
like a big you know sweaty gabon all day
been really really good so I highly
recommend it I am I have their stuff I
wore it all the time on my honeymoon I
wear it all the time now that I'm back
the these are this is also the most
comfortable shirt I've ever worn it's
tailored right to your body I can't say
enough about Peter Millar right now go
to Peter Millar calm slash cough fa CoV
feef a check out some of my Peter
Moeller favorites be sure to use my link
you will receive complimentary shipping
and a free hat that's important by the
way on my honeymoon I got a sunburn on
my scalp and I have a lot of hair it's a
little perk but you get free shipping go
try them out it is my favorite clothing
Peter Miller mi ll AR comm slash cough
fa Peter milord comm slash cough FAC OB
f e f e happy Father's Day everybody was
Father's Day over the weekend I did we
did that round table obviously daily
wire backstage were smoking cigars and
drinking whiskey and hanging out with
the fathers you can go check that out
online also I I was pleased to be at
Reverend Jesse Lee Peterson's event his
men's conference for his organization
bond we talked about you know or the
difference between alpha males and beta
males I kind of reject that language
broadly but it was a good discussion I'm
sure you can check that out too today's
also June 10th nobody celebrates
Juneteenth people don't hear about it
and need more especially if you grew up
in New York like I did you you don't
really hear about it
Juneteenth is to celebrate the
emancipation of the slaves throughout
the Confederacy so that the Emancipation
Proclamation was issued by Abraham
Lincoln in 1862 went into effect right
at the beginning of 1863 but because all
those Democrat states were revolting
against America they didn't pay much
heed to what mr. Lincoln had to say so
on
Juneteenth to the 19th of June Union
Army Major General Gordon Granger
marched down to Galveston he proclaimed
all the good news that the Confederate
slaves were freed you know there were
3.1 million slaves in the Confederate
States and and everybody was very happy
not as happy as the Mexican soccer fans
but they were happy and so you know
people don't talk about this anymore I
think because what the Democrats want to
do is convince
everybody that they're slaves still they
don't want to let people know that
Republicans freed all their slaves so
they want you to think that there's this
awful oppression and that you're really
enslaved and you can't do anything but
it's it's always important to celebrate
emancipation and Liberty it's essential
to the American project and God wants
you to be free and we should remind
people that they are free okay so I
really want to get to the meat of this
show today how these Republicans are
pulling their knives out against Donald
Trump because they're fake Republicans
and they're spreading fake news about
the immigration policies at the border
and the separation of children and
Donald Trump's you know he's like worse
than Hitler or whatever they're saying
before we get to that though the huge
sports news over the weekend I'm sure
you were following major major sports
news so we turn now to our sister
network daily wire to and a sports
analyst Jeremy the god-king boring fam
thank you Michael
Jeremy what happened
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Michael this weekend saw the most
important event in socialist sport since
the soup lines at the gulags it's the
greatest four-year plan since Stalin
himself I'm talking about the fee fie fo
a World Cup it's that special time every
four years when Americans pretend they
care about soccer even though I dare a
single one of them to name more than
three retired players over the age of
twelve from anywhere on earth the big
news of the weekend of course Mexico GDP
one point zero four trillion scouring
their worst upset over Germany GDP three
point four six trillion since the
Zimmermann telegram Mexico delivered
with a10 nail-biter that CBS sports
Roger Gonzalez called a tense hectic
match that would make anybody shake from
the nerves here are the highlights
you
so hectic indeed Germany heavily favored
to win not only the match but the entire
World Cup before you know Mexico Mexico
scored one single goal swore that it
will rise up only one generation hence
and establish a right that will last a
thousand years
in other notable matches from the
opening weekend the world's leading
state sponsor of terrorism Iran GDP 393
billion won only their second match in
World Cup history handily defeating
Morocco GDP one point zero one billion
in group b10 and I thought Iran didn't
have nukes and we're right right hey
Michael hey Michael Michael hey Michael
Michael right and finally in a match
that sports net is calling a game for
the ages
Portugal GDP two hundred and four
billion managed to tie neighboring Spain
GDP one point two three two trillion in
the Iberian Peninsula is most engrossing
conflict since insert Hemingway joke
women and beta males all over America
responded to the match which perfectly
encapsulates everything they love about
soccer from the complete lack of tension
or action to the total absence of any
personal narrative or individual
accomplishments and almost a measurably
small score with a resounding no I
really love football the whole world
loves football
well can't you just agree with us about
football football players are cute four
billion people can't be wrong about
football America is evil this is why you
got Trump the final score was 3-3
representing fully fifty percent of the
total points scored in the World Cup to
date and that's your daily wire to
weekend World Cup update be sure to tune
in tomorrow or next week or whenever we
get around to doing this joke again
seriously this craps gonna last an
entire month Michael BAM back to you
BAM Jeremy that was that was a rousing
arousing analysis thank you so much that
almost managed to keep me awake so it's
a real a real adventure thank you so
much for watching that you know a lot a
lot of big news there was that man-made
earthquake oh by the soccer fan I didn't
watch it Michael
God well God King jeremy boring daily
wire to sports analyst thank you so much
for your
and we look forward to you not watching
more World Cup games and coming back to
tell us about them that would truly be
my pleasure Jeremy the god-king boring
daily wire - it's always great when we
can get our sister network in here to
start to start reporting on things like
that really really good okay I don't
know how you got through that with it
mostly a straight face so I think I just
lost half my audience by the way so now
now we've got to get to the meat of this
the GOP these Republicans this is what
they do they go on TV and they're
Republican strategists or they're former
Republican politicians or whatever they
are coming out against Donald Trump
administration and against Donald Trump
himself here is why Republicans are
attacking the president you know jobless
rates at a almost historic low economy's
taking pretty well stock markets up
don't know that no I don't think that's
why you know I was I was talking about
that really controversial policy that
ever you know that's in the news because
it's in all the headlines that really
really controversial policy can we play
that I congratulate South Korea and
North Korea on their historic meeting
last month the United States is
encouraged by president moon and
chairman Kim's stated goal of complete
denuclearization in the Panmunjeom
declaration guys this is really
undercutting the ridiculous narrative
that fake Republicans are trying to
create in the mainstream media can we
can we please finally roll the clip of
that terrible horrible thing that Donald
Trump is doing on our border illegal
immigration down illegal immigration out
50 60 % that's correct now I mean
thoughts thoughts it's a good question
that's that's not the one either is it
so why are these Republicans turning on
Donald Trump why and they're getting all
these plaudits from the mainstream media
listen I know it has to be happening
because the New York Times told me so
the New York Times ran a headline quote
leading Republicans joined Democrats in
pushing Trump to halt family separations
now what is this you've got to go
through the language word by word here
because when you read it it is so absurd
not only that a New York Times writer
could write these things but then an
editor could let it go through that
people believe this kind of stuff this
is what the New York Times says quote by
laying responsibility for the situation
on both sides mrs. Trump Melania Trump
effectively echoed her husband's
assertion that it was the result of a
law written by Democrats in fact the
administration announced a zero
tolerance approach this spring leading
to the separations now listen to that
they're saying they're saying this
happened but really it's this and so the
allegation here is there Republicans are
saying this is an old policy that was
written in part by Democrats and
Democrat judges but really Republicans
are now enforcing the law those aren't
conflicting statements the statements
make perfect sense
there were Democrat laws that were laws
passed by both parties that have to do
with how we process people at the border
there were rulings made by left-wing
judges on the 9th circuit and then the
Democrats refused to enforce the law
because they're an utterly lawless party
and Republicans are enforcing the law
that was passed by our representatives
duly passed by our legislature and
that's supposed to be in conflict
somehow that's not in conflict at all
the Trump administration is just finally
enforcing the law we'll get to more of
that later before we do that we got to
make a little money honey we got to talk
about AIG travel guard we have a new
sponsor here is AIG travel guard message
and data rates may apply please do not
text to drive insurance offered by
travel guard Burbank and underwritten by
National Union Fire Insurance Company a
Pittsburgh PA for a complete description
of the coverage limitations and
exclusions go to travel guard comm this
ad does not describe actual events and
is used for illustrative purposes only
that so that actually I had to record
that early because that's my really
smoky sultry voice that I do really
quick you know I really like these guys
AIG travel guard this is really
important you know there are a lot of
summer travel plans going on right now I
a fair bit and in the summer I try to
get away a little bit to just go have
some fun you know hang out with my
brand-new sweet little mrs. Knowles and
I got to tell you something I have lost
thousands of dollars in my life this is
no joke thousands of dollars because I
didn't purchase travel insurance and you
know because I'm flying around a fair
bit and I got to go visit this but and
sometimes plans change sometimes someone
gets sick sup whatever and I've lost so
much money cuz I don't want to pay that
little extra bit for the travel
insurance and then my whole flight my
whole trip
gets sunk and I lose a lot of money
don't be like me I mean I'm not gonna
make that mistake again four times when
trips do not go as planned
there is a IG travel Gordon travel
guards staff is available 24/7 to help
you can get coverage for as low as $30
when you text Michael to 48 48 48 just
text Michael mi CH AE l to 48 48 48 you
get coverage for as low as $30 this is
so good I'm not gonna be caught without
this again one time I got stranded in
the UK because travel plans didn't go as
they were supposed to go I really really
wish I had a og travel guard they work
anywhere in the world coverage includes
flight hotel rebooking flight
cancellation interruption or delay lost
baggage delayed baggage medical expenses
evacuation passport or ticket
replacement assistance which is a
problem more than you would think people
love it there are a lot of great
testimonials about this that you can
check out get coverage now for just $30
text michael mi CH AE l 248 48 48 that's
Michael - 48 48 48 mi CH AE l - 48 48 48
okay I want to get to a little bit more
of this so the New York Times just
totally ginning this up out of nowhere
they're saying there is a law and Trump
is enforcing the law and the law was
passed a long time ago and Trump is
enforcing the law by the way other
people have enforced it at times too and
for some reason that's horrible and you
know he's Hitler because everyone who
disagrees with me is Hitler according to
New York Times The New York Times goes
on in this piece previous
administration's made exceptions to such
prosecutions for adults traveling with
minor children but the Trump
administration has said it will not do
so listen to that made exceptions now it
sounds like that's a really not what's
so accommodating it's so it's so nice
and thoughtful and accommodating and
compassionate when our law enforcement
doesn't enforce the law I mean you know
the people who we the people still
theoretically control this country we've
passed laws we've our duly elected
representatives have passed laws but
it's so nice isn't it so nice when the
government refuses to enforce the laws
that the people have passed that's what
they're trying to say so what's the
difference here rich Lowry has a really
good piece on this on these those
images of the babies being ripped from
their mother all this stuff Tom Arnold
was talking about on the show the other
day the reason that you're seeing this
now more now really is just because
there's a Republican in office but in
the old days most illegal immigration on
our southern border was single males
from Mexico and they were coming to get
jobs now over the last 10-15 years that
has shifted dramatically to be more
families women and children coming from
Central America why is that because
we've created a system of incentives
where we weren't prosecuting families so
guess what happens the road to hell is
paved with good intentions all of a
sudden you get more families more young
children being caught up in this awful
depraved criminal enterprise to cross
the border illegally
another thing that changed is largely in
previous administrations we ignored the
law just that's okay it doesn't matter
we don't need to have a border you can
come through that's fine now we're
enforcing the law also by the way these
these the the reason for this is the the
courts especially the 9th 9th Circuit
but also other laws so when these
families cross the border illegally the
the parents are taken in by u.s.
marshals because they've committed a
crime and they're not supposed to be
here the children are not taken in by US
Marshals because they're children you
can't hold them accountable for the
crime they were just brought along so
they're taken in by Health and Human
Services they're put in temporary
shelters this is not a new policy this
has been going on for a long time
including the Obama administration now
what happens at this point is there are
criminal proceedings for the parents
this usually happens very very quickly
it can happen same day where the parents
go before the judge they plead guilty
they are sentenced to time served
because we're a very compassionate
country so we say it's ok we're not
gonna keep you in jail you can now
choose to leave the country and you'll
reunite with your kids today same day
the parents have that ability to do that
now where it gets a little wonky is if
they start to demand asylum or appeal it
or say we don't we want to stick around
for a while
because according to the Flores consent
decree of 1997 kids can only be held for
20 days so after that they have to be
separated so the the Ninth Circuit
ensured that we
can't hold family units together here
that's the trouble this leftist judges
on the Ninth Circuit said that we can't
hold them all together because either
you're holding them with the criminal
parents or you're just gonna let the
parents go those are the two choices you
have and everyone who's trying to
grandstand on this issue those are your
choices or are you going to put the kids
in with the criminal parents because
then you're gonna have to change the law
or are you going to just not prosecute
the illegal aliens and disregard federal
law overturn federal law say we have an
open border we don't have any border at
all those are your two choices you have
just those two choices now fake
Republicans are coming out of the
woodwork to use this as an opportunity
to to gut the president administration
here is a guy named Evan Siegfried we'll
talk a little bit more about him after
here is Evan Siegfried on MSNBC and you
know what Kirsten Nielsen tweeted out
last night that ridiculous tweet that
says we were not having this policy but
on May 10th in an interview with NPR she
talked about the policy and said how
great it wasn't how she was going to
implement it so she's either a liar or
suffering from severe mental or memory
loss and we talked about how President
Trump wants to make America strong and
great again our greatness and our
strength comes from our morality and our
compassion and this administration is
absolutely devoid of it absolutely how
does this help America I don't put my
hat on it from a fiscal perspective I
put my hat on from a moral perspective
Anthony scaramouche II this morning was
saying well the president will probably
reverse because it's just bad optics not
bad optics much he was in the White
House for 11 days and I know he wants to
become the next James Carville but that
doesn't qualify him to recognize or fail
to recognize that it's bad morality it
shows us to be an uncompassionate and
immoral people and it also sends a
terrible signal to the rest of the world
with Republicans like this guy who needs
Democrats this is the worst kind of
Republican it is so deceptive and so
treacherous and so backstabbing a he I
refer to guys like Evan as Republican
but not that kind of Republicans you
know the ones who all they want is
MSNBC's approval they what they're the
good ones they're not like those bad
ones they're the good ones like what do
you want what are you trying to have
Liberty are you trying to support
Liberty are you trying to support the
United States are you just trying to get
famous by stabbing your ostensible
friends in the back absolutely
disgusting and as for your moral
argument Evan Siegfried
according to fusion and Amnesty
International 60 to 80 percent of women
and girls who cross the border illegally
are raped on that journey
what is compassionate what is moral
about incentivizing and encouraging that
system because because you have that on
your hands buddy even if you are saying
that we shouldn't be prosecuting we
should be creating incentives for these
young women and young girls to come
across the border then you have moral
responsibility for those rapes on your
hands so I'm going preen on it MSNBC I'm
glad at least MSNBC got religion Donald
Trump seems to have trolled them into
reading the Bible on air the other day
so that's good but it's absolutely
disgusting and these guys go on and they
preen and they throw moral accusations
when they are the ones who are morally
culpable and we're trying to be nice and
civilized about it but when you hurl
that kind of trash at your ostensibly
fellow Republicans you can't let that
stand absolutely awful he's not making
any moral argument he's just sitting
there and saying you're bad you're evil
you're Hitler I got two words for you
Evan Siegfried and they are not happy
birthday from Susan Collins the fake
Republican a senator she writes quote
what the administration has decided to
do is separate children from their
parents to try to send a message that if
you cross the border with your children
your children are going to be ripped
away from you know they're doing it
because it's the law they're doing it
because it's the law and they are
supposed to enforce the law
because we are a nation of laws not a
nation of men these Democrats and these
anti Trump Republicans attack Trump for
being authoritarian they are the ones
advocating authoritarianism he is
enforcing the law finally he's not
trying to be capricious and selectively
prosecute certain people and not others
he's the one saying we need to follow
the law and it's these these
authoritarians are the ones accusing
Donald Trump of being exactly what they
really are Susan Collins goes on
she says this is traumatizing to the
children who are innocent victims it is
contrary to our values in this country
open borders is not a value in this
country incentivizing the rape of women
and girls is not a value in this country
just pathetic sophistry and this brings
us to mrs. Laura
bush mrs. Laura Bush wrote an op-ed in
The Washington Post where democracy dies
in darkness attacking this
administration in the most vicious terms
so we'll have to talk about it mrs. Bush
said quote I live in a border state
I appreciate the need to enforce and
protect our international boundaries but
and I know what you're thinking is I
just read that sentence and that sounded
fine
and then she said but and you know you
know what's gonna follow is a complete
negation of what she just said because
of buts negates sentences almost all of
the time says okay yeah we need to
protect the border yeah yeah but this
zero tolerance policy is cruel it's
immoral and it breaks my heart okay if
it's cruel then why weren't you agitated
to change the law why wasn't when this
was happening under the Obama
administration why weren't you arguing
to change the law Barack Obama was
actually enforcing this at various times
in his administration I didn't I don't
remember an op-ed from mrs. Bush or
others then do you I don't remember that
either she goes on our government should
not be in the business of warehousing
children right yeah they shouldn't be
coming into the country and their their
criminal parents shouldn't be bringing
them into the country and opening them
up to the horrible dangers that
accompany crossing that border with all
of the drug cartels who facilitated and
all of the legal ramifications for
committing a heinous crime a truly awful
crime which is at the first act that one
person does when they come into a
country is to violate some of its most
sacred laws determining who can come in
and who can come out that isn't that is
a real crime and some Democrats argued
to say it's just a misdemeanor and I
suppose technically that's true I'm on
the first time the second time it's a
felony but regardless the crime itself
is so so cuts to the heart of a country
to determine who gets to be in the
country who gets to access its
taxpayer-funded services who will have
to be dealt with by the criminal justice
system who ultimately could vote in its
elections in shape its politics and
shape its government that is so cuts to
the heart of of the government that it's
a really really awful crime Laura Bush
goes on this is really awful she goes
these images are eerily reminiscent of
the japanese-american internment camps
of World War two
now considered to have been one of the
most shameful episodes in US history
this is where mrs. mrs. Bush delves into
all of my enemies our Hitler everyone
who disagrees with me is Hitler during
Japanese internment the United States
rounded up some of its citizens and put
them in camps in this case people are
flooding over our border and we're
trying to deal with them and we're not
even deporting them immediately we're
trying we're giving them the opportunity
to go back but we're trying to deal with
them as humanely as possible nobody's
asking them to come over
in fact we're telling them explicitly
please do not but policies such as the
policy is being advocated by mrs. Bush
and other administration critics here
are incentivizing that flow in creating
this this crisis at the border this this
crisis that they have created themselves
a totally awful and to compare the
enforcing laws that were on the books
during your husband's administration
during the Obama administration to
compare enforcing the law to Japanese
internment is really disgusting really
awful I can't believe that was allowed
to go through finally she says Americans
pride ourselves on being a moral nation
on being a nation that sends
humanitarian relief to place is
devastated by disasters and famine and
war we pride ourselves on believing that
people should be seen for the content of
their character not the color of their
skin I'm gonna hold off right here is
she now calling them racist is this net
it's racist now to enforce the law cuz
that's what she's saying she said Tom
Arnold called Republicans racist on my
show I can expect that from someone
who's you know a sort of a more
left-wing activist someone who's doing a
show to try to get down Donald Trump but
this is the former First Lady of the
United States ostensibly a Republican
saying if you disagree with me or a
racist really vicious as she then says
we pride ourselves on acceptance well I
don't know what that means like what do
we do we accept evil do we accept
do you accept crime do you accept is
that that's what you accept do you
accept all that awful sexual crime that
occurs at the border because of those
incentives no that's an empty statement
right if we are truly that country then
it is our obligation to reunite these
detained children with their parents and
stop separating parents and children in
the first place read between the lines
it means stop enforcing border
protections and just let illegal aliens
flood our country that's what it's
really saying
people on all sides agree that our
immigration system isn't working I don't
agree with that I think it is work I
think if we enforce the law then the
immigration system is working we know
actually we know that it illegal
immigration dropped dramatically at the
start of the Trump administration why
because people thought they weren't
gonna be allowed to get in then when
they saw that this system is pretty hard
to change the numbers ticked right back
up and they started flooding over again
and they started using children as human
shields to get into the United States
but we know that this is voluntary
immigration we know this is mostly
economic immigration because if it were
truly all cases of asylum then those
numbers wouldn't have dropped right when
they when they when they thought that
they could would not be allowed in and
would be sent back those numbers dropped
that that makes it clear that it's
largely voluntary
but not not for mrs. Bush's sadly
demagogic article she says people on all
sides agree it isn't working but the
injustice of zero tolerance is not the
answer in 2018 can we not find a nation
that can can we not as a nation find a
kind ler more compassionate more moral
answer to the crisis and he or she gives
away the whole story listen to those
words kinder more compassionate this is
a really terrible lot bad really awful
to her fellow Republicans and fellow
Americans but because she's basically
calling people who support enforcing
immigration law on having a border
racist and comparing them to Jeb the
people who've behind Japanese internment
but this is something the bushes have
always done when George HW Bush ran for
president 1988 he said we needed to
become a kinder gentler nation and mrs.
Reagan to that answered kind ler and
gentler than whom what do you mean
kinder and gentler you the Reagan
administration lasted for eight years
George Bush was vice president there and
then he says we need to be kinder and
gentler he's calling conservatives cruel
when George Bush jr. george w bush ran
for president 2000 he promised a
compassionate conservatism as though as
though conservative thought is cruel in
the first place but he is going to make
it compassionate the Bush's have never
been conservatives they came from the
establishment wing of the party they
were brought into the Reagan ticket to
to tie up the fissures in the Republican
Party between the Conservatives and the
establishment it's great
awful incentives so just a quick little
rundown 80% 80% of women and girls 60 to
80 percent according to Amnesty
International and fusion raped and
sexually assaulted crossing into the
border also an estimated 78 percent of
the guides who are bringing people
across that border or under the age of
18 that's a little weird when we talk
about these detained children a lot of
them come over unaccompanied a lot of
them are with adults who are not their
parents who are who are bad guys who are
trying to bring them over as human
shields they're under 18 the drug
cartels started to use young children
children under the age of 18 as the
guides because they knew that the United
States wouldn't prosecute them so what
do we do with them actually during the
Obama administration Barack Obama
detained a number of them because they
were such a key to the human trafficking
problem at the border he detained 536 of
them in less than a year of course that
was never reported on
if only mrs. Bush had attacked Barack
Obama in this way for anything not just
this policy but for all of the
destruction that his presidency brought
on our country but no during that
administration then it was better for
former presidents and their families to
stay quiet that that was the dignified
thing to do and I sort of respect that
actually but now that it's a Republican
administration it's good to start
attacking them for enforcing the law for
trying to advance some conservative
public policy absolutely awful the
reason that this is happening you
remember about a month or so ago there
were those images of kids being detained
by immigration and there at the border
and they all the Obama administration
officials said this is awful this is the
end of the world this is terrible
then they found out that those photos
were taken during the Obama
administration all of a sudden they shut
up about it they wouldn't talk about it
anymore because it's just trying to take
cheap points at Donald Trump and the
reason they focus on this the reason
they have to create this fake crisis is
because the Trump administration is
doing too well so the economy is doing
very well
foreign affairs are going great going
gangbusters even the IMF is admitting
that we're helping the global economy
rice so much so they they have to create
this crisis is it is it awful what's
happening is it awful to see a child
separated from his parent in the cases
where it actually as a parent and
actually as a child yes that's
horrible that's terrible and that has
all been created by the sick and
perverse incentives in law was passed in
part by Democrats judicial decisions
that have come down from left-wing
judges on the ninth circuit and by those
squishes and those left wingers who
insist that we not enforce the law
creating incentives that have children
taken away from their parents
conservatives and Republicans should not
give one single inch on this it's just
awful and the Republicans who come out
and use this to take cheap shots against
the administration should be ashamed of
themselves and they should have their
GOP card ripped away from them separated
at the border of politics okay
we've got to get to George while we're
running a little late right now so we
got to get to him if you're on Facebook
and you too - I'm sorry what can I do
you got to go to daily wire.com you'll
get me you get the Andrew Klavan sure
you get the Ben Shapiro show it's ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership none of those perks matter at
all because you need the leftist tears
tumblr mmm there it is went oh is that a
World Cup viewership ratings are down
over 50% this year in the United States
is that hmm oh that's good that tastes
real real good go to daily wire.com
we'll be right back with the theologian
George Weigel
[Music]
all right George
Weigel distinguished senior fellow at
the ethics and Public Policy Institute
he is a leading Catholic theologian in
the United States and an all-around
great public intellectual
he holds the ethics and Public Policy
centers William East Simon chair in
Catholic studies he has a new book out
the fragility of order Catholic
reflections on turbulent times I spoke
to George at the end of last week he is
always very interesting to talk to
here's the interview mr. wykel thank you
so much for being here nice to be with
you Michael I really really enjoyed your
book the book is the fragility of order
Catholic reflections on turbulent times
I'd like to begin a little before that
though in 2016 because I loved a piece
you wrote in first things where you used
a quotation to describe your feeling of
that election you said do the Germans
have a word for euphoric dread and I
think that about sums it up now you know
almost two years in has you have your
feelings changed on this are you more
comfortable with the presidency or is it
still a bizarro world that we're all
living in I'm very grateful for a number
of things that the president
administration has done particularly in
terms of the federal judiciary
employment situation seems to be
considerably improved the pressures off
on religious freedom at least as that
pressure was coming from the executive
branch in the Obama administration but
the recent business in Singapore where
the president praised one of the three
worst dictators in the world has a very
talented guy with a good sense of humor
and all of this and then a few hours ago
said presumably jocularly well I wish
people would sit up and pay attention to
me like they do to kim jeong-hoon look
you know 12 hours before I had had
dinner with six North Korean defectors
who are working on on human rights
issues in North Korea today you don't
joke about this stuff this is this is
not a joking matter this is a terrible
regime and if we don't understand that
we're not going to get a particularly
satisfactory deal if any deal is is
possible with these guys well this gets
to a point in your book which I really
loved
in the essay the importance of reality
contact because I think the way that
Donald Trump himself has explained his
comments and compliments to Kim jong-un
is he's saying oh you know I'm just
saying words and they don't mean
anything and I'm trying to butter him up
for a deal and the implication here is
that oh it doesn't matter what I say I'm
just using words instrumentally you
write in that essay public policy that
fosters individual human flourishing and
the common good must take account of
reality and realities when a culture
loses confidence in its capacity to say
with conviction this is the way things
are its capacity to devise ways and
means of addressing the way things ought
to be is severely eroded and you know I
had the actor Tom Arnold on my show the
other day he said with a straight face
there is no such thing as a single
objective reality I go to college
campuses students tell me all the time
there's no objective truth there is your
truth and my truth and George's truth
and his truth how did we get to this
point this disrespect of reality and how
do we get out of it well we could spend
the rest of our time together tracing
this back to David Hume and Immanuel
Kant but let's let's fast forward here
and and take up your your college
student who says okay Michael there's
there's no such thing as the truth
there's only your truths and my truths
the next thing to say to that person is
okay what happens when your truths and
my truths collide and neither one of us
recognizes something called the truth by
which we can settle the argument what
happens is you impose your power on me
or I impose my power on you this is what
Cardinal Ratzinger
on April 18th 2005 called the
dictatorship of relativism it's the end
of democracy it's a radical constraint
on freedom and it's a terrible problem
throughout the Western world today the
inability to say that anything is true
except my willfulness the reduction of
freedom to sheer will is the death of
freedom of course and theirs it creates
chaos and there have been a lot of calls
for order you know the Jordan Peterson
the Canadian psychologist sold about a
gazillion books on the topic of creating
order out of chaos it does seem like a
willfully chaotic time and I wonder if
there's any way back you know the it's
it's been so long if we can trace this
back to David Hume or perhaps even
centuries further back the the
beginnings of this how do we return to
that political order or is it just
all-out out of Pandora's box and you
know the age of chivalry and Glory of
Europe are all dead well the age of
chivalry certainly seems to have died
but perhaps we could recover something
called common sense good manners some
grasp on the truth in the essay in the
book called a new Great Awakening I
sketch out a coalition if you will of
people of biblical faith and and people
who have not been given the gift of
faith but who nonetheless recognize that
there are truths built into the world
and into US and that living according to
those truths makes for both personal
happiness and and social cohesion and
true freedom that was the coalition that
made the Revolution of 1989 possible in
Central and Eastern Europe but was built
during the 1980s by both believers and
unbelievers it was inspired in large
part by John Paul
and who had a talent for bringing
together people of very different
backgrounds and that's not that long ago
it's not that long ago but unfortunately
I'm afraid we are going to have to
experience more chaos more repression in
the name of tolerance before before
people wake up to the fact that there's
a serious problem here well I loved the
essay a new Great Awakening and it
struck me because our pal Andrew Clavin
has been saying that we're on the verge
of a new Great Awakening for a while now
as well and one wonders always what that
would look like it occurred to me that
the two founders were putative founders
of the American conservative movement
Russell Kirk and the William F Buckley
Jr both share a certain affinity as do a
you and I for a smells and bells and
Roman things the in this ostensibly
Protestant country we've got the
founders of American conservatism or
these two Catholics but why does the
American conservative movement have this
Catholic flavor to it and does that play
any role in our new Great Awakening well
I think Catholic social doctrine ought
to play a role in this because Catholic
social doctrine with its vision of the
free and virtuous society another issue
addressed in this book is really based
on the natural moral law you don't have
to believe in the Immaculate Conception
of the Blessed Virgin Mary to engage
Catholic social doctrine you just have
to be willing to work through an
argument seriously this was the genius
of leo xiii in the late 19th century
understanding that the modern world
needed a kind of grammar for ordering
the conversation about the human future
and Leo's answer to that was okay let's
let's find the moral truths and scribed
in the world and in us truths that we
can know by reason that creates a kind
of grammatical system by which we can
actually talk to each other the recovery
of that throughout the Western world
is is really essential in the early 21st
century but when we're speaking of chaos
and order the Catholic Church as it
stands seems to have gone from a period
of wonderful order of Pope John Paul the
great and Pope Benedict to a confusing
period right now and I get all of these
questions in the mailbag from Catholics
and non-catholics asking me about the
apparent confusion from Pope Francis or
from people reporting on Pope Francis
what are we to make of this not only as
Catholics but as Americans and people
living in 2018 I think people should
understand first of all that the
Catholic Church knows what it believes
it's in the Catechism of the Catholic
Church that hasn't been repealed and
Pope Francis recently celebrated its
25th anniversary my other suggestion to
people is to calm down don't spend your
time in the Catholic blogosphere where
it's all hysteria all the time from all
sides and to recognize that the living
parts of the church whether you're
talking about renewal movements in the
developed world great parishes and
America campus ministries like focus or
the vibrant church all over Africa today
one of the great evangelical success
stories of the last century these are
all the parts of the church that have
embraced Catholicism in full and the
dying parts of the church are the parts
that are still trying to make the
Catholic light project work and it does
Catholic light is boring
there's nothing engaging and enlivening
about it and if you want evidence of
that look at the church in the
german-speaking world today immensely
rich the Catholic Church in Germany is
the second largest employer in the
country because of its wealth and yet
there's five to seven percent mass
attendance why is that the case because
they keep trying to
catholic light work and catholic light
doesn't work because it's uninteresting
that's so true I have to say I was a
cradle Catholic and then I sort of fell
away around the time of my confirmation
and to me the the liturgy that I knew
was acoustic guitars and you know the
the priest says some nice sentimental
words about something and then you all
applaud at the end and I don't know they
probably have kumbaya added in there or
something in all of these suburban
churches and the experience of a
traditional liturgy or of a more
traditional engagement with the the
church itself it was totally new and I
think there's a whole generation of
people for whom that is totally new but
this is what really worries me you see
these numbers of no religious
affiliation rising dramatically when you
look at Millennials and the generation
after Millennials you see a huge drops
in marriage rates and expect higher even
higher expected drops in marriage rates
to continue no religious affiliation
very low mass attendance is there any
way to act to not just have a new Great
Awakening with some new coalition but to
create a new religious movement in the
United States or is that a lost cause no
it's not a lost cause the gospel is
never a lost cause what what everyone in
the Catholic Church has to recognize is
that culturally transmitted Catholicism
Catholicism by ethnic inheritance I'm a
Catholic because my great-grandmother
came from County Cork or whatever right
I'm a Catholic because I'm an Italian
and therefore don't button all of the
buttons on my shirt right that's over
that that's over throughout the
developed world and the church has to
become a much more intentionally
evangelical and missionary enterprise
which I devoted a whole book called
evangelical Catholicism to to explaining
the living parts of the Church of the
parts that have figured that out and
they are making headway even among
Millennials who may before that before
the gig is up
make us baby boomers look good by
comparison you know a lot I hear a lot
of these millennial conservative
and they'll say they'll say I'm
spiritual but I'm not religious I don't
want any religious affiliation oh you
know Republicans should stop talking
about gay marriage that's over
they should stop I suppose pro-life is
actually on the rise but what what do we
make of an issue such as the
redefinition of marriage is that a lost
cause from the perspective of American
conservatism or does marriage have a
definition and we need to keep barreling
along at defending that traditional
definition no matter how unpopular
politically it is well I think it's a
bad idea when the state tries to make us
all believe it's something we know isn't
true is true I mean that that was the
reason to fight that battle this was a
vast overreach on the part of the state
the state doesn't define marriage
marriage is a human institution that
antedates the state both historically
and and is prior to the state if you'll
pardon the word metaphysically it's it's
a more fundamental institution I
actually proposed six or seven years ago
maybe even longer than that that the
Catholic Church in the United States get
out of the civil marriage business in
other words to stop having deacons and
priests act as officers in the state
signing state marriage licenses because
what the state meant by marriage in
those licenses and what we mean by the
sacrament of matrimony are two
fundamentally different things my older
daughter was married five years ago and
the celebrant was bishop Jim Connelly of
Lincoln Nebraska
he asked me to mail back to the state of
Maryland the marriage license which he
had signed I looked at it the day after
the wedding to make sure everything had
been filled out properly and instead of
saying husband wife bridegroom
man-woman it said spouse 1 and spouse 2
and then you had and this is signed by
James D Connelly Bishop of Lincoln this
is a complete disconnect right we should
acknowledge that people can have a
civilly registered marriage but the
church shouldn't be saying that what now
every state in the United States has
been compelled by the supreme court to
mean by marriage is what we mean by
marriage you just it's a falsification
of reality and as you were saying a
moment ago reality contact is kind of
important if we're gonna get things
right in public life well I find when I
speak to people about political issues
these days especially in the Trump era
where the resistance has turned up their
yells and shrieks and net gnashing of
teeth to a fever pitch they will get
louder and louder the more they're
presented with incontrovertible facts
you know you'll just point to the
unemployment rate and they'll they'll
just start yelling and shouting you down
how do we bridge this there is virtually
no common culture anymore people don't
watch the same TV shows they don't watch
the same movies they don't go to the
same church they don't believe the same
basic things they don't even share the
same basic love of country how how is
how will it be possible to bring
everybody back under this one reality or
are we gonna crack up and fall apart
well let's let's take a look at
something you mentioned a moment ago the
increasingly pro-life views of the
American people I've been involved in in
pro-life work for almost 40 years I've
written a lot of stuff on this I've made
a lot of arguments I am willing to
recognize that what has really turned
this around is the sonogram is is
technology which makes it impossible for
the other side to say this is the
equivalent of an appendix or a tumor
this is not that and you can see that so
we need to figure out the imagery side
of other issues we also need to keep
calm we don't have to debase the public
conversation the way this resistance
nonsense does we have to be the people
of lucidity and reason and good manners
and hope that over time that will have
an effect people don't like to be
shouted out all the time and the more
the resistance shouts the more it
weakens its case there was a enormous
difference between that really
unspeakably vulgar resistance rally here
in Washington a few days after president
Trump's inaugurated the one with the
pink hats and all of that yeah with all
that stuff and the March for Life a week
or so later the first was angry
vulgar nasty in-your-face
the latter was happy joyful celebrit
Orry young increasingly female and much
more attractive by any reasonable
measure so it's never it's never give up
time we've been through some very rough
patches in this country before and I
think part of the shrill and shrill Ness
and hysteria of the present moment
particularly among younger people has
something to do with the profound
ignorance of history that that is now
part of the public landscape when when
half of American college graduates last
year did not know that Franklin D
Roosevelt was the president during the
Second World War
how do we expect them to know that there
was a huge mess in this country between
1850 and 1860 or that the country was
really on it's knocked back on its heels
during the Great Depression and so forth
and so on a recovery of of the story the
story of America which includes the
story of American renewal there's
immense their immense sources of renewal
in this country and we should tap those
and that is such an important point the
narrative the from all the way from the
sonogram to the narrative we live our
lives in narrative we live our lives in
a story and when you can illuminate that
story then you appear as you say happy
and joyful and attractive and that's
pretty good I like a world that's happy
joyful attractive and increasingly
female that's a good world to me and a
good note of hope to end on I've got to
let you go I've taken up enough of your
time the book is so so good the
fragility of order Catholic reflections
on turbulent times since nobody has
educated these days and everybody has
been deprived of reading books during
their schooling start with this one
because it's a very good one and it will
illuminate a lot of what is going on in
our culture I really enjoyed it
mr. waggle thank you so much for being
here thanks for having me it's very
important that you start with books such
as mr. Weigel's the fragility of order
so that you can move on to really you
know esoteric sophisticated books like
reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide but you need to
start out with theology and philosophy
and cultural commentary so that you can
move on to the greatest political term
in the history of our republic okay
that's our show come back tomorrow
even the soccer fans who I've doubtless
alienated from my show now I didn't
realize how many people liked soccer but
anyway even then please come back and
I'll see you tomorrow I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolan show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Knowles oh is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you